so let's keep let's stick with the same
repertoire
um a lot of people playing g6 these days
uh what to do no need to take back
immediately maybe now
let's take now if it takes
it's just gonna get weird attack
attack the bishop allowing this
yeah so the point is it's actually a
positional kind of
decision is that
i have a dark sport bishop and dark
square is our
are kind of weak positions kind of open
like queen h4 okay so i want to play
this and rip d1
brian the eggman egg are the eggman
i am the walrus who caught you
isn't that like a beatles song there's a
beatles song called i am the walrus
let's play yeah castle and
open file the opponent wants to do the
same thing
i'm thinking f4 on password and queen
takes queen
but opponent wouldn't on poisson
you play rook d4 trying to trap the
queen
knight d5 also interesting this is a
fascinating position
i'm not sure what to do in rook d4 it's
very forcing let's play rook d4
because the queen's gonna get kicked
around
like a soccer ball
wait what do what should they call a
soccer ball in europe
because you don't use the term soccer
just call it a football
oh you call it a football okay
because football yeah i guess that makes
sense
uh what to do bishop c5
hmm okay well now black can't castle i
bishop here
too which almost traps the queen
yeah i'm still playing soccer or
football
europeans never ever say soccer again
uh my deepest apologies
it's so difficult though because that's
what i was born and raised
to call it the real question is what do
they call a football hall in europe
but in australia i think australia has
some weird terminology too
let's play
like b5 just keep kicking the queen
if here maybe i can i take
and then if queen here i move back and i
win the rook
this is so fun this is how i'm getting
exercise
oh i dropped a rook oh this is not fun
why did i drop a rook that was such a
terrible decision
that was really bad let's take a night
yeah this is really bad i got too
too wrapped up in the terminology of
sports
um bishop b5 is interesting
i mean the good thing is that i'm used
to being down material
so i'm threatening this to double fork
yeah all forks are at least double
sometimes triple
there's a pin so the the queen can't be
taken
i might want to play this move soon
i suggest us europeans should start
calling american football soccer
what oh in your fa wait okay let's focus
let's focus
uh let's take a ruck first
yeah the corn stream that's a nice term
yeah i don't know where my queen goes
probably here and then this move and
then i'll try and win the bishop
i'll probably be down at night in the
end
it could be worse oh but the king can
move up
it's unfortunate g4
i have to keep throwing punches oh but
i'm so long time
play play the smooth threatening this
i still have initiatives somehow
initiative is so important the f4 next
a 423 oh that's a good move
let's play f4 anyway
queen a1 scares me but then i'll just
run
and try and hide now f5 common
guaranteed
oh this move
10 seconds left
where's my mate what's so close to mate
it's so close to meat
i was so close yet so far
ah i lost what to do
oh no i'm sure i had forced me somewhere
it was so close there were so many
different checks to choose from
because the king was so exposed
and probably this is best yeah just this
and then queen f5 it's just force mate
know what to do just to show here
if here it's me and only other legal
move
oh there's this move but that's meat
so this is mate and then this is also
just meat that's so sad could have won
that
[Music]
was that my first loss that was my first
loss
entertaining game kind of but very
painful